I love that I've I've Loved a lot of
things that you said that's my favorite
thing so far thank you my man attention
is the number one asset most things are
more fair than people want to think
people want to blame a president people
want to blame their parents people want
to blame blame blame we've gotten
remarkable at pointing fingers nobody
wants to do this [__] for sure people
have like almost cut their [__]
thumbs off like people don't want to do
this [__] and to me I'm not trying to be
like motivational or rough it's just
very very obvious to me there's a direct
correlation of happiness and
accountability I love that I've Loved a
lot of things that you said that's my
favorite thing so far thank you my man